all right hey what's going on welcome to
my kitchen and as I mentioned I told you
I was going to show you how to make a
pie crust right the [__] holidays are
coming up who's kidding you didn't do
[__] with your life right you haven't
done anything you're not bringing
anything to the table you don't have any
kids
maybe you got busted for [__]
drinking and driving you just don't fit
in with your family that you got to do
something right here we go
you make a pie crust all right this is
what you're gonna need you're gonna need
one of these a rolling pin
[__] pin of this thing pastry cloth I
have a board thing I don't know what
this is called all right so maybe this
is a graphic up right now this thing and
you got you got two types of these
things you got this one this is an old
one the most warming style no the other
do that I [__] hate you on that it
makes a lot of noise just this was my
grandmother's right I just took it from
all right she died two cups of flour and
this was the the all-purpose gold metal
flower it's not that gluten-free save
the [__] lives
whatever it's like look you're making a
pie already you know anything it's not
gonna be pigmented it tell yourself
you're gonna go to gym so there's two
cups of this and you also put solvent so
you just go like this but you take the
one cup dump it in like that they should
run cup of the lentils myself right here
then I put this salt right over there
you're getting that are you getting that
you put the salt just like that done
with that you take this thing here you
just are you doing this go like this I
don't know why you do is look at see oh
it's in there it looks a little
different there right it's almost 60
movies they work with their products and
they make sure you don't steal any all
right so at this point I mean I'm a
five-year-old could do this
everybody gets freaked out about babies
you know the name like though what's
gonna happen what if I [__] it up who
cares
nobody's watching you it's not like
they're filming it all right so this is
hanging butter baby's crust so you want
eight ounces of it never because I kind
of [__] do I measure that well it has it
right here look at see they make it nice
and easy right eight tablespoons I
should say I'm a dope two three four
five six seven eight it's a whole that's
all got dipstick so you want to have
this [__] cold you don't wanna have it
at room temperature this it's going to
be too mushy so then you just take it
like this you watch the hands
and you just cut it up like this alright
cut it up you drop it in there you
getting that Andrew leave for the people
at home you know it's funny somewhere I
don't know why and I don't know who but
somebody is probably jerking off to this
because it is the internet oh yeah
what's the head butter in the [__]
flower man I've been wanting to see a
bubbling redhead do this there's one one
an eight-point-two everybody makes fun
of it but it would you would you blow we
get that bit any difficulties you just
go to bed bathroom right on the street
fine so now the problem is if you start
going like this with the butter is just
gonna get in here it's gonna be a pain
in the ass so what I try to do is I just
kind of used usually just I get
everything covered in the flour you see
that just like that now now what you
wanted to what you want to do if you tap
too hard the butters gonna get stuck in
this you start off tapping lightly
alright
and then you gradually build an
intensity this is you know essentially
what all those women's magazines say
women like you please them in bed this
is like the foreplay
oh wow that is a beautiful dress oh yeah
how many brothers and sisters do you
have
oh that's interesting this is the hard
part of doing cooking Charlotte this is
usually one like Rachael Ray will just
tell some [__] story like this reminds
me when we like up in the cabin I'm sure
one time and I was a dog again
I think she's on medication and that's
sort of the consistency you're looking
for there a little cornmeal type of
thing
oh how [__] ridiculous is it that
ability change it makes it too much
you're gonna get it you got to get a
tough across to think you're Crisco all
focus grease every real mother who still
beats their children and cooks and stays
at home like women should say yes and
they get a crystal you just do the same
thing you just cover a little bit of
flour so it doesn't stick to whatever
the [__] this is called stick handle
with it a little bit you know I'm go
Phil Kessel bless Sidney Crosby here
right by the way all you guys are like
oh why do they have to half times in
hockey first of all the math doesn't
make sense there will be a third in a
2/3 time okay so now so now you get to
this you got that consistency going
there you know it's jazz time to come
together this is like your pieces are
shortening and butter right that's what
you want to have mostly lace so now they
say four to five ounces
I like to use what I do is I go like
this and then I just you know whatever I
pour like like that much in whatever I
don't know what that is then you take it
and you put this stuff on top you give
it a little twist like a [__] kid in
a mud club all right same thing again
here we go
there's only disgusting South Elizabeth
Sega so it's not totally nixed it's
mostly mixed or whatever so now what you
want to do come over here you bored here
that pastry cloth so it doesn't stick
just take a little bit of flour like
this plop it down a little so they're
trying to make like a little ball of it
here like that
that's pretty [__] good huh now for
most people you haven't [__] up
already if you haven't screwed the pooch
this is where you separate the [__]
something from the something this is
where it usually goes to [__] so what
you do is get a little this this way a
little [__] that way like this now
already stop looking at that going oh my
god what's gonna happen did I [__] it up
you did all right you just keep going
like this and just trying to work it
like you know you're trying to make like
a circle here's your you should try this
you know you know what you don't you
know a circle is right you're right
you're an adult
alright so now this is basically what
you got this looks like a big goddamn
mess doesn't it like like how the hell's
that gonna fit
this right keep working in here right
and by the way I can't wait to when you
post this the amount of people that are
gonna be giving me [__] well you should
have done all right you just take a
little bit of this crap ain't you grease
it up yeah now this thing is this is an
absolute [__] ship that does not mean
you see there's a crust you can see that
it's there not a [__] you get this into
that and they have it somewhat look like
this look how perfect there's this
[__] bastards look at that
consistency just straight-up ants is
what you do this right here this is the
[__]
right so you just basically go one two
three
BAM just like that yeah you don't even
think about it you know it's like
breaking up with somebody you don't want
to be with you just sit down what's
wrong it's just it's just like this one
two three are you both just like that
you take this part over here and boom
now you're like God well I'm still gonna
[__] fit so now what you want to do is
you want to push this down so it lines
the whatever you give the pie plate here
if you go like that it's gonna rip so
what you do is you lift this up like
this that's how you do it like that
oops no one's ever gonna know all right
you push things down just start making
dents fit here everything worked out
there you go there's your pie crust a
little bit of flour there a little bit
of flour there's nothing and then
theophil is whatever the [__] you want
to put in there you know just start off
with some some of your grandmother's
recipes you know if you think it's
underseasoned or over seasoned you know
if you're making an apple pie not enough
cinnamon throw some more [__] set
them in there so check it out that's not
bad that's not bad it's [__] underneath
it shut up there you go [__] Billy
pie crust for Christmas